[Music]
Channing Tatum is adjusting to life as a
single man making his first public
appearance since announcing his split
from Jenna Dewan you can do that without
just grinning the entire time two
bachelors hitting the racetrack in
Alabama
Channing wasn't wearing his wedding ring
yesterday during his first post-split
appearance but he did share the day with
perhaps the most hated bachelor ever re
Channing was the grand marshal at the
Honda Indy Grand Prix in Birmingham and
I witnessed lzt he was in a great mood
and did not shy away from the attention
of fans Channing's ex Jenna has also
been stepping back into the spotlight
yesterday she was spotted without her
ring while shopping at a farmers market
and on Friday she made her first
post-split red carpet appearance in
Manhattan Jenna's date was her father as
she was honored with a Humanitarian
Award at the st. jude hope and heritage
gala she was absolutely stunning in an
embroidered Zuhair Murad gown she
instagrammed this shot with the caption
quote love you dad
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]